we are all atomically connected
fundamentally universally but what does
that mean I'm an astrophysicist and as
such it is my responsibility to trace
the cosmic history of every single one
of your atoms in fact I would say the
one of the greatest achievements of
modern astronomy is the understanding of
how or atoms were actually put together
while hydrogen and helium was made
during the first two minutes of the Big
Bang the origin of heavy elements such
as the iron in your blood the oxygen
we're breathing the silicon in your
computers lies in the life cycle of
stars nuclear reactions take lighter
elements and transform them into heavier
ones and that causes stars to shine and
ultimately explode and therefore in
reaching the universe with these heavy
elements so without stellar death there
will be no oxygen or other elements
heavier than hydrogen and helium and
therefore there will be no life there
are more atoms in our bodies than stars
in the universe and these atoms are
extremely durable the origins of our
atoms can be traceable to stars the
manufacture them in their interiors and
exploded them in all across the Milky
Way billions of years ago and I should
know this because I am indeed a
certified stellar mortician and today I
want to take you on a journey that
starts in a supernova explosion and ends
with the air that we are breathing right
now so what is your body made of
96% consists of only four elements
hydrogen carbon oxygen and nitrogen now
the main character of this cosmic tale
is oxygen not only is the vast majority
of her bodies made of oxygen but oxygen
is the one element fighting to protect
life on Earth the vast majority of
oxygen in the universe was indeed
produced over the entire history of the
universe in the supernova explosions
these supernova explosion signaled the
demise of very massive stars and for a
brilliant month one supernova explosion
can be brighter than an entire galaxy
containing billions of stars that is
truly remarkable
that is because massive stars burn
brighter and have a spectacular deaths
compared to other stars nuclear fusion
is really the lifeblood of all stars
including the Sun and as a result is the
root source of all the energy on earth
you can think of stars as these fusion
factories which are powered by smashing
atoms together in their hot and dense
interiors now stars like our Sun which
are relatively small burn hydrogen into
helium but heavier stars of about eight
times the mass of the Sun continue this
burning cycle even after they exhausted
their helium in their cores so at this
point the massive star is left with a
carbon core which as you know is the
building block of life this carbon core
continues to collapse and as a result
the temperature increases which allows
further nuclear reactions to take place
and carbon then burns into oxygen into
neon silicon sulfur and ultimately iron
and
is the end why because iron is the most
bound nuclei in the universe which means
that we cannot extract energy by burning
iron so when the entire core of the
massive star is made of iron it's run
out of fuel and that's an incredibly bad
day for a star without fuel it cannot
generate heat and therefore gravity has
won the battle
the iron core has no other choice but to
collapse reaching incredibly high
densities think of 300 million tons
reduced to space the size of a sugar
cube at these extreme high densities the
core actually resists collapse and as a
result all of these in falling material
bounces off the core and these dramatic
bands which happens in a fraction of a
second or so is responsible for ejecting
the rest of the star in all directions
ultimately forming a supernova explosion
so sadly from the perspective of an
astrophysicist the conditions in the
Centers of these exploding stars cannot
be recreated in a laboratory now
thankfully for Humanity they were not
able to do that but what does that mean
that means that as astrophysicists we
have to rely on sophisticated computer
simulations in order to understand these
complex phenomena these simulations can
be used to really understand how gas
behaves under such extreme conditions
and can be used to answer fundamental
questions like what ultimately disrupt
the massive star how is it that this
implosion can be reversed into an
explosion there's huge amount of debate
in the field but we all agree
that neutrinos which are these elusive
elementary particle play a crucial role
yeah I'm about to show you one of those
simulations so neutrinos are producing
huge numbers once the core collapses and
in fact they are responsible for
transferring the energy in this core
like thermal radiation in a heater
neutrinos pump energy into the core
increasing the possibility of disrupting
the star in fact for about a fraction of
a second neutrinos pump so much energy
that the pressure increases high enough
that a shock wave is produced and the
shock wave goes and disrupts the entire
star and it is in that shock wave where
elements are produced so thank you
neutrinos supernova shine bright and for
a brief period of time they radiate more
energy than the Sun will in his entire
lifetime that point of light that you
see there which was certainly not there
before burns like a beacon clearly
indicating the position where the
massive star has died in a galaxy like
our own Milky Way we estimate that about
once every 50 years a massive star dies
this implies that somewhere in the
universe there's a supernova explosion
every second or so and thankfully for
astronomers some of them are actually
found relatively close to Earth various
civilizations recorded these supernova
explosions
long before the telescope was invented
the most famous of all of them is
probably the supernova explosion that
gave rise to the Crab Nebula yeah korean
and chinese astronomers recorded
the supernova in 1054 as the almost
certainly Native Americans these
supernovae happen about 5,600
light-years away from Earth and he was
so incredibly bright that astronomers
could see it during the day and he was
visible to the naked eye for about two
years in the night sky
fast forward a thousand years or so
later and what we see we see these
filaments that were blasted by the
explosion moving at 300 miles per second
these filaments are essential for us to
understand how massive stars died the
image that you see there was assembled
by the Hubble Space Telescope over a
span of three months and it is
incredibly important to astronomers
because it ultimately carries the
chemical legacy of the star that
exploded the orange filaments that you
see there are the tatter remainings of
the star and our main primarily of
hydrogen while the blue and red
filaments that you see are the freshly
synthesized oxygen so studying supernova
remnants like the Crab Nebula allowed
astronomers to firmly conclude that the
vast majority of oxygen on earth was
produced by supernova explosions over
the history of the universe and we can
estimate than in order to assemble all
the atoms of oxygen in our body it took
of the order of a hundred million
supernovae so every bit of you or at
least the majority event came from one
of these supernova explosions so now you
may be wondering how is it that these
atoms that were generated in such
extreme conditions ultimately took
residence in our body no so I wanted to
follow this you know the the thought
experiment imagine they were in the
Milky Way and a supernova happens it
blasted tons and tons of oxygen atoms
almost in
two empty space a few of them were able
to be assembled in a cloud now
4.5 billion years ago something
unsettled that cloud and caused it to
collapse forming the Sun in its center
and the solar system so the Sun the
planets and life on Earth depends on
this beautiful cycle of stellar birth
stellar death and a stellar rebirth and
this continuous recycling of atoms in
the universe and as a result astronomy
and chemistry are intimately connected
we are life forms that have evolved to
inhale the waste products of plants but
now you know that we also inhale the
waste products of supernova explosions
so take a moment inhale an oxygen atom
has just gone into your body it is
certain that that oxygen body remembers
that he was in the interior of a star
and it was probably manufactured by a
supernova explosion this atom may have
travel the entire solar system until a
splash on earth long before reaching you
when we breathe we use hundreds of
liters of oxygen every day so I'm
incredibly lucky to be standing in front
of this beautiful audience but I'm
actually stealing your oxygen atoms
and because I'm speaking to you I'm
giving you some of them back the ones
recited in me so breathing yeah
participate in this beautiful exchange
of atoms and you can then ask well how
many atoms in our body wants belong to
frida kahlo about a hundred thousand of
them a hundred thousand more probably
long - Marie Curie a hundred thousand
more to Sally Ride or whoever you want
to think of so breathing is not only
filling or lungs with cosmic history but
with human history I would like to end
my talk by sharing a myth that is very
close to my heart a myth from the
teaching mecha culture which is a very
powerful memory can culture and the to
make us believe that or essence was
assemble in the heavens and on its
journey towards us you'd actually
fragmented into tons of different pieces
so my abuela used to say one of the
reasons why you feel incomplete is
because you are missing your pieces but
don't be fooled by that you'll be given
an incredible opportunity of growth why
because it's not like those pieces were
scattered on earth and you have to go
and pick them up no those pieces fell
into other people and only by sharing
them you will become more complete yes
during your life there's going to be
individuals that have these huge pieces
that are made you feel whole but in your
quest of being complete you have to
treasure and share every single one of
those pieces sounds a lot like the story
of oxygen to me which started in the
heavens in a supernova explosion and
continues today
within the confines of our humanity or
atoms in our body have embarked in an
epic Odyssey with time spans from
billions of years to Mare centuries all
leading to you all of you witnesses of
the universe thank you
[Applause]